quite some trouble wow can we take a
look at that knight g4 trick
yeah and this was actually the moment
young christopher mentioned uh i think
maybe here were you expecting a
different move maybe just rook takes
bishop or yeah rick takes bishop then
probably go queen d4 and
try to fire it down this way but it
didn't it didn't look very good
um
and instead he attacked your queen yeah
and this yeah so knight f6
uh also here rook f
also here rg1 was interesting uh okay
okay i thought
after
this yeah
and i was kind of taken to e4 and then
i thought maybe you can take on c5 okay
wow some tricks some some tricks yeah
and then he'll he'll win my queen um
and then i thought i'll take
i'll take the rook um
and the crazy material in balance here
magnus yeah evaluate this type no it's
not time to evaluate yet i have to go
rook g7 i think okay and then f5
wow
we're seeing all of this even though
you're playing so quickly
yeah but it's pretty
kind of straightforward and i thought
rookie 70. rookie 7 there's d6 so i
thought maybe i'll have to take the
bishop on g6 and
and go for some tricks in in that in
that line like takes and then okay and
then bishop f5
rookie 8 tried to pin that
in that bishop
and who knows lots of pieces lots of
pieces it looked it didn't look like
obviously losing for me at least maybe
this position is actually it's actually
good who knows
anyway
um i was not so interested in trying to
find great continuations for him because
i thought in the last few months i
didn't have much choice anyway i was
just
trying to stay afloat